but you've been in the game for 25 years
you're a property millionaire the last
five six seven years haven't done a lot
and then then I joined the academy and
what happened then
my life changed you've tripled your
income in property in the last six
months yeah yeah 100 that's insane
though and it all started with a one
pound event why couldn't I have met some
your leads 10 years ago when he was
starting out my daughter's lovely she
went to University she got a degree but
if I knew what I know now I would have
said to her eight years old when you're
18 I'm Gonna Get You On The Academy
you'll be a property millionaire by the
time you're 20. yeah I love that this is
serious unplug yourself from the Matrix
and be financially independent but
you've got to have the education
[Music]
property millionaire being in property
now for how many years about 25 years 25
years you bought your first buy to let
when I was six years old so you've been
in the game a lot longer than I have
you've got a nice big portfolio leaks
options rent to rent
your own buy to lets you've built a
house before with your brother and um
making a great income from property so I
wonder if it'll be okay if I could just
pick your brain and pass the information
down to maybe the next generation and I
know you've helped your kids as well
yeah yeah your daughter's just become
financially free yeah and I wanted to
tease you the information from you
through this interview so firstly thank
you brother for coming to the house oh
pleasure where you from Wolverhampton
same as me where are you buying houses
uh so most of our properties are in
Wolverhampton my dad started in 1978
with uh student-led accommodations hmos
when there wasn't hmos back then so I
kind of grew up around
students and hmos and saw all the
regulations I came in
um later on I think I was 16 or 15 uh
GCSE time Christie just came around what
do you want to do when you grow up and
you know a major saying accountants
listers doctors and I was like I'm going
to be a property developer but at that
time you know the education wasn't there
all I knew was you work save money buy a
house right that's it that's the only
strategy that was going and whether you
did a family by to let or you did a HMO
type by delay there was only one buy to
let HMO was kind of became a thing
afterwards uh once the government found
out that you're making too much money
right once I wrote my first book and
then they changed all the rules you let
the secret out yeah I wrote boiler right
behind 2016 and I basically told
everybody what I was doing in
Wolverhampton yeah to find cheap houses
for 100 grand renting them out room by
room making a fortune and a bank Article
4 came in what do you think Billy in
terms of opportunity you've been through
you've been in the game longer than I
have you've seen the 2008 crash yeah
um obviously that was when I came in the
1990s the 1990s crash which I was I was
too young to remember that because I was
just a kid
um do you think now is a good time to
get into property or do you think now do
you think it's kind of like the
opportunities are gone now it's never
too late it's never too late
um
as long as you hold the property and you
don't think of like I don't sell
properties I've never been into flipping
because just my mentality has always
been around holding and just wait for
capital appreciation so even if you pay
20 grand over the odds today yeah you
know in five ten years time that's gonna
grow there's gonna be Capital there for
you to pull out
um so yeah it's never a wrong time to
get into property my daughter's getting
into property now my nephews are getting
into property now so yeah never too late
and back in the day you used to buy
properties the traditional way which is
why but you'd save up money you'd buy a
bite to that house you know rent it out
are you still doing that or do you have
you completely changed up your strategy
now so we were doing that through the
early 2000s then we kind of slowed down
after the 2007 crash
a couple of priorities changed my
brother built a house uh just a little
two-bedroom house I've kind of got
the gist of how all that works
um and then the last five six seven
years haven't done a lot and then then I
joined the academy and what happened
then
my life changed talk to me about it
oh man what do I say about the Academy I
I love the academy absolutely love it
I was born to be on the academy and I
say this to my daughter I was like why
couldn't I have met Samuel leads 10
years ago when he was starting now
because that's what I needed I needed
that education I knew the basics but
rent to rent rents service accommodation
do getting a two-bedroom house
converting into a four bed HMO uh lease
options I didn't know deal packaging I
didn't know any of this stuff
and learning all this stuff
was amazing from the academy and then
then the networking you get it's so
powerful
I I don't think I talked to anybody
outside of the academy anymore
if somebody calls me and they're not in
the academy I'm like yeah I'll deal with
them later on that's not important but
if somebody from the academy calls on
like yeah straight away how can I help
yeah what can I do for you because
you've created the academy and that's
the environment you've created for for
everybody to come in and everyone's
there to help each other out that
doesn't really happen in any other
Walker life where people are sharing
their Trade Secrets their experiences
and like just your basic bits I was
talking to somebody in the academy just
this morning about
they've got a a one bedroom flat in bath
the landlord doesn't want them to put it
on Airbnb they're only allowing them to
put it on booking.com you know and just
advising them of how how to how to
navigate that situation and that was at
six o'clock this morning
I was having that conversation so I mean
you it doesn't happen anywhere else so
like the thing is with you be like is
because you're already successful in
property and you've got a portfolio that
you built up traditionally you can
appreciate more than anybody how awesome
the academies and the value of the
training because it's like you've been
in the game for a long time you know
would it be fair to say that you you've
tripled your income in property you
doubled the size of your portfolio in
the last six months yeah yeah 100 that's
insane though 100 how can you double the
amount of properties you've got and
triple your income in six months when
previously you've been in the game for
25 years we call you in on the academy
we call you the lease option Kink lease
option because you do just constantly
every week on The Mastermind you're like
just negotiated this lease option just
got the keys for this talk to me why are
you doing lease options lease options
what a amazing strategy I think I think
everybody's after a lease option it's
like um
it's the mythical creature everyone's
after one and
I think it's difficult to go out hunting
for one I've just accidentally Fallen
across them
but when you say accidentally because
I'd had the training of the Academy I
knew what to look out for knew the signs
the distress signals from landlords or
vendors seeing what they needed at that
time and then offering it that option as
a last resort and it's surprising how
many of them take take the deal what are
you saying then for what no let's start
with who would be a good candidate for
release auction agreement and what is a
lease option agreement what is it so the
first one that I took over was a
landlord
um he the flowers in negative equity
what does that mean you bought it for a
hundred thousand in 2005 2007 crash
happened the prop never recovered right
Flats just don't recover as fast as
houses do right exactly so now is his
mortgage is worth is a higher prize than
the value of his house yeah and the
flats still hovering at that 2008 price
right so if he sells it tomorrow for a
hundred percent of the current value
he's still gonna have to pay off his
mortgage and some so he's completely got
nothing in this house no he's got
nothing left in it right and situations
in his life uh whatever happened
um he just looking to offload yeah
happened to be in the right place at the
right time with the right knowledge have
the right conversation give him the
right answers
um picked up a lease option and what is
the lease option basically take over his
mortgage payments yeah we take over the
bills we take over everything to do with
the property
um and we pay him in seven years time so
so basically you've got an option to buy
the house but you fixed the price now
fix the price now so what was the what
was the price that you fixed uh uh 80
000. so you can buy of 80 000 anytime in
the next seven years if you don't buy it
then after seven years the option of
restriction is lifted yeah and what do
you reckon is going to happen to the
value of that in the next eight years
it'll go up to about a hundred thousand
dollars yeah I'll push the value upon
that
um probably like in a couple of years
time maybe update the kitchen a bit
update the bathroom a little and it
might be that the property prices I know
at the moment property prices are
falling right now but it might be that
in seven years it's doubled in value
yeah who knows you don't because
eventually if house prices are going up
and apartments are really cheap sooner
or later the house prices automatically
drag up the apartment and we had a big
long conversation about apartments
didn't we at the least option boot camp
yeah about the prices of them yeah how
they come in and out of fashion yeah
yeah so how much how are you going to
make money on this thing because if
you're taking over his mortgage and he's
got a big fat mortgage and interest
rates are really high he's he fixed the
mortgage recently for 248 pounds okay
um so that's that was a really good deal
I've given that lease option to my
daughter to live in because she was
previously living in a HMO right so
because she's helping me with the essays
and she's working with me you know six
seven days a week so she's learning
earning and learning
um so I've given the least option
apartment to her she's moved in we're
going to rent out the second bedroom
um for 550. the bills are 250
say another couple of hundred pound for
gas electric water broadband
so that rental
uh washes his face doesn't it yeah a
house like I think they call it yeah is
it I think it's an American term it's a
house so she basically lives there for
free yeah house hacking yeah so she's
right she's renting the property she's
renting a dirt cheap for 248 band a
month yeah she's renting out one of the
rooms that's covering her she's
financially free she's financially free
you know one deal right and the house is
gonna go up in value and you you're
getting all the equity from it so we're
not making any monthly money off it but
she's now got a home made her
financially free
um and now we're just concentrating on
building up the rent to rent essay
portfolio and uh the rent to rent HMO
portfolio we've just taken on a six bed
HMO which which also comes with a lease
option agreement
how that one came about
an accidental landlord
uh doesn't want to really deal with HMO
uh tenants uh he's happy to offload it
he is a house Builder
by trade so we went there to offer him a
management agreement
to take on the HMO the conversation went
on
would you would you consider selling it
yes he would
what's it worth 235 I think he said and
I put my hand down I said I'll buy it
235 if you're happy with that and he
went
you're not going to negotiate the price
I said no no I'll give you 235
but I'll pay you in seven years
giving you the approach you want but I'm
paying you on my terms but that's at the
end of the lease anyway
during your seven year lease in the
meantime
if you're saying Tim look I'll rent it
from you yeah for seven years and at the
end I'll buy it yeah that's it how much
rent are you paying him
um so we're still negotiating how we're
gonna structure because if we get it as
a management
um I've just got to pay him a thousand
pound right and I've got six rooms all
of them ensuite so you'll be making a
nice profit every month yeah minimum
thousand pound a month profit on that
minimum uh and then with that thousand
pounds a month profit if you save that
yeah so at the end of the seven years
use that as a deposit to buy the house
that's it yeah free house free house why
work hard and save for deposits when you
can just agree to buy a house now and
pay for it later and then pay for it out
of the rent yeah it's such a powerful
strategy and again without the Academy I
want to learn and you've also sold a few
deals
yeah so deal sourcing is not really my
strong point you're a passive deal
saucer yeah so like accidental deals but
it's still paid for the Academy yes it's
paid for the Academy I think I've sold
about three or four deals
um and it was just deals that
I personally didn't have the time to
take on and convert to essays so it was
like okay let's just package that sell
that on and we've got that cash flow
coming in just to Tires over but yeah
rental essays where I'm kind of focusing
at the moment a lot of people think that
rent to rent is something that you do
when you've got no money and you you
can't afford to buy houses you're just
getting started but you've been in the
game for 25 years you're a property
millionaire you really understand the
game
um you've built houses why you do rent
to rent rent to rent is a good strategy
especially for my daughter coming into
it who doesn't have any money
who doesn't really have the same
experiences as me I help her to Source
the rent to rent properties teach her
how to furnish it how to get it all set
up Airbnb booking.com all the platforms
Channel managers housekeepers ring
doorbells minute sensors uh hives
teach you how to set it all up
she can now continue growing her rent to
rent portfolio which is going to give
her that income
where she can save that income to buy
her first house right to get her on the
property ladder so you really your
motivation for all of this is your kids
isn't it yeah the kids yeah yeah she
went to University she got a degree but
she was the child at eight years old
when we were getting her private tuition
at home and stuff just didn't sink into
her head yeah like me it would literally
go in this year and two minutes later
it's out it's gone and and she'd stand
there crying at eight years old saying
dad I just don't get it
I'm sorry I just don't get it I need to
break my heart and I promised her at the
age of eight that I will get you to
University that's my job as a dad get
you to University
but if I knew what I knew no now
about all these strategies
I would have said to her eight years old
don't worry about it when you're 18 I'm
Gonna Get You On The Academy you'll be a
property millionaire by the time you're
20.
yeah I love that but I didn't know that
then yeah and and it was so good meeting
your daughter though yeah she's a big
fan she's got a great energy as well
she's very you know she's she's a she's
a great a great lass yeah she's lovely
she cracks me up she she's very much
like me
um like same kind of sense of humor
um I think once you first met you he
wasn't a handshake she went straight in
for a hug yeah I was like easy last time
he'll lead that is yeah no she's she's a
great a great person and what what what
what are your family then sort of
thinking about what you're doing and how
you're changing the Next Generation
nobody knows I joined the academy you
didn't tell anybody nobody knows why did
you answer Liberty
to stay away from negativity
yeah I didn't want any negativity around
me I knew what I was doing
I know these strategies work
and I just need the chance to get in the
academy learn them Implement them then
show right okay this is what we're doing
so this is this is it this is there we
did it I mean but the fact that you made
back your Academy fee which is what like
12 Grand yeah from literally just
selling a couple of deals that you
didn't want how can anyone argue with
that yeah you know what I'm saying like
you're out taking on properties buying
houses you've doubled your portfolio
you've tripled your income in property
but also you found a few deals that
didn't really quite work for you and you
just said oh I'll pass them to another
investor yeah and I mean I mean how can
you argue that that's awesome deal
sourcing is so powerful I mean there's
people on the academy who are just
making a full-time career at a deal
selling oh yeah turning over 25 35 Grand
for for a joke yeah the DNA yeah and
you're talking a month right now not a
year 25 30 grand a month a month and
like people are doing jobs earning 20
grand a year
I'm like this is crazy yeah this is
serious uh blue pill unplug yourself
from the Matrix and be financially
independent but you've got to have the
education yeah what's been one of the
best moments for you over the last six
months
in the lease option yeah yeah getting it
out of that HMO put her in see the smile
on her face
just so she's got a place now she can
call home yeah she's the landlord of
this lease option she's now going to
have a tenant that she's responsible of
looking after she's got guests that she
looks after not my job it's her job to
look after all that my job is to come
out and just enjoy the trappings of the
academy which is all the functions the
dinners uh the networking events I love
that side of it I still come to all the
one pound events which are local to me
um sometimes I'm crewing sometimes I I
just turn up say hello to everybody and
at the team uh have a laugh and a joke
with them and and they've become like
family and that's kind of what you got
to do there you've got to become part of
the furniture because yeah when you're
constantly around people that are
winning
it just rubs off on you doesn't it who
you hang around 100 100 and you you say
that all the time and all through my
life
even before joining the academy
all my friends are millionaires
some are Engineers some are in property
all sorts of different businesses but
they're all millionaires I just levitate
towards that yeah that Arena and I think
it was something my cousin might have
said to me who was a millionaire himself
when I was 20 years old
surround yourself with like-minded
people yeah so I've always surrounded
myself with Millionaires and you've been
a massive asset to the academy as well I
know you've you've received a lot and
it's been life-changing for you but
you've been a massive asset because
you've taken a lot of people that are
just sort of starting out under your
wing yeah yeah and you've been a mentor
to people as well as being mentored yeah
you know yourself which we're really
really grateful for what would you say
the biggest key is to winning in
property
the freedom to make changes
and I think
where I see myself in a couple of years
from now
um
would be doing more charitable stuff
like what you do whether it's in India
or whether it's in Africa giving back in
some way creating a legacy I think
that's a good way to say it to create a
legacy where
even after you've died you've left
something where the world can remember
you yeah so like creating Wells
supplying fresh water
um my mom does some charity out in India
um so maybe
contribute more towards that help her
with that where we
um sponsor orphans pay for their
education my mum also does some
charitable work where she takes Brides
from very poor families in India and
pays for their wedding wow and it's so
important as well because when you get
to when you reach the top of the
mountain I'm not saying you've reached
the top of the mountain but when you
become successful and money is kind of
No Object anymore you're making more
money than you can spend sometimes it's
easy to actually actually feel a bit
depressed about it because it's like
well what now yeah you can help your
kids which you've done and you can help
your family but unless you're actually
doing something that's fulfilling and
you're moving somewhere and you're
making the world a better place I think
it can be quite unfulfilling because
reality is
living in a nice house having a nice car
it's great but ultimately unless you've
got some a reason why a fulfilling
purpose I think um you know you're never
gonna have true content even before I
joined the Academy I was kind of
financially free at that point in my
life
and
it is just a really boring place to be
what was the reason then what was the
motivation to join the academy when you
were making a decent living passive from
property property millionaire why why
join the academy there's a couple of
things one I was bored
I hadn't really hit
the peak of where I wanted to be I was
comfortable
but not the next level
where I always wanted to get and then a
couple of conversations with my daughter
in passing she'd made a couple of
comments about property and
we got China said I didn't know you're
interested in property I didn't how did
you know the answer to that I I haven't
taught you that and it was just her as a
child being around me and her mom
talking about property talking about
business so we started having a
conversation she's like I I want to
learn about property
and then I thought well okay now's a
good time to join the academy it's a new
lease of life for me because now I feel
like a 21 year old myself running around
talking to agents calling up agents that
I knew from the past getting some deals
and getting essays set up you know
working 10 12 hours a day seven days a
week
I feel young again rebuilding my
relationship with my daughter that's
been amazing
because we had been estranged for a
couple of years
um
so yeah that that was that was the
reasons why I joined the academy and
you're planning to send your daughter on
The Academy soon yeah 100 yeah that's
awesome bro also if you want to come out
I'd love to invite you to come out to
Ganda with us I'd love to let's make
that happen yeah absolutely just to
learn from you get some direction
because it's it's all like I said it's
okay making the money
then what what yeah there's only so many
restaurants you can go to at least so
many holidays you can have it's only so
many cars you can buy there's got to be
some meaning in your life you've gotta
you gotta be giving back somewhere
something that's going to give you that
fulfillment where you know where you can
sleep comfortably at night knowing that
you've put some good back out there what
would you say to somebody that was
thinking because you know we run one
pound courses yeah sometimes it sounds a
bit too good to be true people are like
oh really of course with Samuel in
person for a pound
what would you say to someone that was
thinking about coming it's a no-brainer
it really I mean and you put so much
into that one pound event I mean it's
like a seven eight hour event for a
pound if you can't get up and book a
ticket for a pound
you deserve to be a failure in life you
deserve what you have but if you're
gonna put the effort in come and listen
to someone who's a multi-millionaire
who's doing everything listen to him for
seven hours talk
and then if you want to go on further
education do it invest in yourself you
will make it happen but it's not a get
rich quick scheme where you're going to
get some knowledge and you're going to
sit at home thinking yeah I'll Be A
Millionaire soon you've got to put it
into practice you're like I'm working 12
hours a day seven days a week not just
on the essays but networking helping out
with Academy members having
conversations chasing agents and you
know everything that goes I live and
breathe properly I always have done
which is why this is like a second lease
of life to me and it all started with a
one pound event
well we appreciate I appreciate your
your complimentary words and it's been a
pleasure working with you and I look
forward to continuing to do so if you're
watching at home you heard what Billy
said I'll leave a link in the
description one pound on me one pound
come down let's spend the day together
let's get you started I'll leave a link
in the description
[Music]